un jour je ne sais un jour pour toujours
je m'en irai mais surtout pas d'adieu
sur le quai
en ce chanteur à tour
on se dira rien
en ce dense tout
une dernière fois
on sera bien
avion ses chansons
on a manqué les
lumières c'est galère
me manque
bignona
chose de ma vie
à moi
c'est vrai ya des îles des vignes des
idées
j'ai pas visité parce que j'ai chanté
tout l'été
j'ai en temps tellement à souffrir amis
il faut que mes enfants
et le temps
de me voir qu'en dire
e
en modèle de fortune
vous me manquez
public sous la lune
me manquerait
mais si la division moment les choses de
ma vie à moi
pourtant je ne sais ce soir pour eux
soir
c'est moi qui viendrait dans le noir
m'asseoir sur le quai
je vous verrai la barre
sortir de ma vie
et je ne saurais pas
je suis
à votre avis
peur de la nuit
en temps de studio
petit feu sous la pluie
musiciens géniaux
de vous tourner la mémoire dos
me quittera jamais
un jour je ne sais qu'un jour
pour toujours